c'est la force de leader que l'on
qualifie de populiste d'avoir une
communication ou une rhétorique plutôt
qui est une république qui n'est pas
standardisée c'est ce que fait madame
Meloni manifestement
rhétorique qui s'inscrit en effet dans
une culture politique qui en effet assez
proche de ce que sont les orateurs pour
qualifié de populiste elle dénonce elle
alterne l'interpellation de la salle
l'interpellation des auditeurs
l'interpellation des militants
la demande
Mabo ici
[Applaudissements]
un ton plus personnel plus confidentiel
elle a une rhétorique qui est en mesure
de casser un peu le rythme comme s'il
fallait en permanence
continuer à maintenir l'attention du
public
elle vise à retourner les arguments de
ces adversaires pour
rassurer banaliser
des diaboliser
ce que ces adversaires souhaiteraient
peut-être qu'elle soit j'ai lu que la
victoire de Fatal edithal et aux
élections de septembre conduiraient en
deux astres en tournant autoritaire à la
sortie de l'Italie de l'euro et à
d'autres absurdités de ce genre rien de
tout cela n'est vrai il a plusieurs
décennies que la droite italienne a
relégué les fascismes à l'histoire notre
position dans les camps oxydantal et
transparente et cristallines comme nous
l'avons démontré une fois des plus en
Condens
la brutale agression rousse contre
l'Ukraine ce qui a aussi de tout à fait
intéressant c'est que elle pratique une
forme de retournement des arguments de
ces adversaires notamment sur la
question de la peur
cet argumentation pour dire ce n'est pas
nous qui avons peur mais c'est eux qui
ont peur de notre montée en puissance
c'est une rhétorique où il n'hésite pas
à d'une certaine manière mettre en avant
j'allais dire leur personnalité qui a la
surjoué c'est ce que faisait en effet
Trump c'est ce que faisait en son temps
Jean-Marie Le Pen et c'est ce que c'est
ce que fait madame Meloni manifestement
elle appuie fortement sur une gestuelle
elle appuie
fortement sur
un langage corporel ou elle n'hésite pas
par un certain nombre de mimiques par
d'un nombre de gestes à appuyer sa
parole comme si il s'agissait à la fois
de mettre en branle tout son corps et
j'allais dire toute sa sémantique pour
convaincre son auditoire ils disent de
toutes les ressources de leur
personnalité et juste de toutes les
ressources j'allais dire de leur
gestuelle et de leur corps pour un
moment donné véhiculé un système de
conviction est véhiculé leur
argumentation